j'aime beaucoup les chiens
il y en a dans l'équipe d'ares dimat que
tout le monde adore vous le voyez en ce
moment sur votre écran il s'appelle
zappé je laime beaucoup moi aussi je
dois vous dire fessiers lardy matt
descend en dessous de 15%
nous serons obligés de tuer si chez le
mâle chantage c'est comme ça je vois
également rappelé les ambitions de cette
émission
ce sont celles du service public faire
de la qualité sans oublier l'audience
sans négliger la qualité tout en faisant
de l'audience c'est très clair n'est ce
pas d'autre part de nombreux
téléspectateurs ont été choqués par le
sort réservé à asa notre petit chien
dans le cas où l'art dit matt descendre
en dessous de 15%
je tiens à leur rappeler qu'à la
télévision tous les moyens sont bons
pour arriver d'autres téléspectateurs
n'y croit pas et pensent qu'il s'agit
d'un gag c'est mal me connaître
c'est oublier que si vous zappez je suis
viré d'accord
[Applaudissements]
je vais maintenant vous rappeler les
principes de mon émission pendant un peu
plus d'une heure vous allez voir des
documents exceptionnels que j'ai choisis
pour vous j'espère qu'ils seront vous
plaire car comme on vous l'a assez
répété si vous zappez je suis viré je
sais je sais que beaucoup d'entre vous
verrez la chose sont trop de regrets
notamment monsieur georges chossat de
nantes
milhas ap vous connaissez tous ap
je sais les français aiment beaucoup les
animaux
moi aussi un bon petit japonais il est
joli hein ah il est très joli très bien
et très bien toilé t11 mon petit
japonais
[Musique]
vous avez compris s'il hardy matt
descend en dessous de 15%
je bute le club s'est vu mon petit zappe
alors soyez gentils et regardez mon
émission jusqu'à la
[Applaudissements]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir bienvenue sur le plateau d'art
dimat avant de vous présenter ce
quatrième numéro je voudrais m'adresser
à ceux pour qui le fonctionnement de
l'émission n'est toujours pas clair
qu'est ce que le principe cardinal c'est
vous qui en téléphonant au 36 65 7 1 2 3
fait monter lardy maths ou descendre
s'il descend trop bas
le chien est tuée je suis viré si le
monde vous retrouvez la semaine d'après
le type de sujet que vous avez préféré
par exemple cette semaine un tiers de
sexe un tiers de violence un tiers de
bagnols bref la routine de la télé
thierry feery mardi matin c'est descendu
en dessous de la barre des 15%
[Musique]
sans rancune table marianne personnel
zap a tué là nous appeler tu l'as dieu
soit loué à laventie that comment ça va
mon petit à pune déjà six hardy matt et
il est toujours là qu'est ce qu'on dit
aux téléspectateurs
on dit merci merci merci parce que
l'audience n'est jamais descendu en
dessous de 15%
il veut pas mourir antijaponais aux non
non non non non non non non je veux pas
mourir avant que les abonnés ne veut pas
mourir pas mourir maintenant il veut pas
mourir tu as entendu parler des
philippines ont ils à poney c'est ce qui
leur font là-bas au chien d'audience non
seulement il les tue non plus il les
mange mais ça arrivera pas ici parce
qu'ici les gens ils vont regarder hardy
matt jusqu'à la fin ah oui ça je pense à
m mais à dire vous regardez jusqu'à la
fin jusqu'à la fin oui oui oui oui
thierry parviendra-t-il à sauver la vie
de zap le plus fidèle ami de l'audimat
ça dépend de vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup d'entre vous ont été écoeurés
par le sort réservé aux chiens
d'audience philippin là bas lorsque
l'audience d'une émission chute
ils sont abattus par la chaîne est
mangée par les téléspectateurs
et ça nous a plu et ne veut pas non non
non non non non non non monsieur
audition vous n'allez pas recommencer
avec ce pauvre appelons là je vous ai
déjà dit que mes adhérents regarde alors
ficher vu la belgique a regardé un tu
veux rester en vie nous à pune oui oui
mais tu sais mon japonais il ya aussi
des chiens d'audience très heureux tu
vas voir billy le chien d'audience de
nbc
une vraie star là bas nous a tous nous
regarde
[Musique]
c'est un beau sujet monsieur ardisson ça
c'est un beau sujet j'espère que tout le
monde va bien regarder sinon une petite
balle dans la tête
oui petit à petit de d'ardisson de ce
que je raconte que je dise de mots pour
moi mascarade à des émissions comme ça
tout seul de la foudre dans la
télévision
c'est pas étonnant combattons briochin
non mais c'est pas vrai
abruti pareil mais c'est comme ça les
gorges a dit non et sera acquittée en
plus vous allez laisser cette bestiole
tuba badr à toute attaque c'est moi qui
devrait la voir rachel jong au repos
dans la tête je te le dis moi c'est pure
est quelque part tu ferais c'est
insulter sans rien des très bons pour
nous pouvons vous engueuler plus
l'audiencement avant et madame sert de
vous savez qu'il le fouette le chien est
ce que les chiens ça me dégoûte
j'aimerais vu les gueux l'âge des chiens
ça pue le ch comme toi ça me tient le
choc depuis pas breton évident la
vieille non mais qu'est ce que ces
jeunes sont enroulés mois à venir dire
un truc ça pète le clan des veuves sept
clubs démord pas parce que j'ai débuté
mon chez moi j'étais dans la gueule
jédir connaît
[Applaudissements]
j'espère pour moi c'est bon pour
l'audience parce qu'elle m'a pas rater
la wii mais thierry ça valait la peine à
manger c'est tout à fait bon pour
l'audience il faut souffrir un peu avant
pour faire de l'audience là c'est bon
c'est bon c'est très bon c'est même trop
bon thierry on est de nouveau en sursaut
à il va falloir trouver quelque chose
pour faire redescendre un petit peu la
pression là on est sur le point
d'exploser
vous avez été des millions à nous écrire
pour nous parler d'eux à beaucoup
d'entre vous se sont émus de son sort
dans l'hypothèse où l'audience d'art
d'islemade décembre est en dessous de
15% mais peut en revanche savent ce
qu'ils arrivent à zap les semaines où
l'émission a bien marché
voici un reportage tourné samedi dernier
sur la vie heureuse d'un chien
d'audience récompensés grâce à vous
accor
plusieurs
on a décidé à briser une très bonne
soirée de gala
tu veux retirer aussi d'ailleurs mis sur
sa piste
[Musique]
moi
mua
[Musique]
on sait très longtemps
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais
la paire eur
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
thierry quel beau souvenir c'est ce que
c'est ça non pas papier ouais la note de
chez michou samedi dernier à on a payé
une consommation 43 1831 francs au repas
22 1179 divers 807 francs total 61 1500
francs dont tva douze mille 300 francs
avec nos remerciements à ceux qui disent
qu'ils n'aiment pas ce connard
d'athlètes notre concert se voir deux
personnes professeurs oui eh bien mon
cher thierry compte tenu de ce que ce
charmant petit chien nous coûte
il serait fortement nécessaire de
regonfler l'audience parce que sinon
nous n'allons pas pouvoir assurer vingt
dix les jeunes
[Musique]
tout ça pour un ça va
alors professeur sans voix le bois non
oui je dirais même thierry que c'est
royal top et le fait que vous marchiez
comme un clown en entrant dans ce studio
ne gâte rien
[Rires]
est ce qu'il savait et professeurs quand
on fait ce que les gens veulent ils
aiment mais oui à tel point qu'il y a un
léger risque pour nous maintenant de
dépasser notre quota de parts de marché
je me demande s'il ne serait pas
nécessaire pour faire baisser l'audience
de mettre un petit coup de jacques
martin et si ça ne suffisait pas
peut-être un petit morceau de laurent
ruquier encore que j'espère qu'il sera
pas nécessaire d'en arriver là ça va
marcher
l'audience va baisser professeur à la
tienne mon petit facteur à écouter ça
mon pote tu vas - on dirait du sang des
vierges que c'est bon dillon tu penses à
venir chercher du mouron hillion ça
marche vachement fort a pour l'elysée il
paraît qu'ils ont fait 48 % 48 % dans
les sondages nord dans les écoutes
[Rires]
dites donc
sur tf1 les reality s'ouvre de plus en
plus loin c'est vraiment plus en plus
loin que les horaires prévus
on se couche à trois heures du matin là
pour savoir qui a sauté la petite fille
fazila tu seras une mode pour que
l'abonné femme s'approche
arte a demandé à être mises sur écoute
arte a demandé à était sur écoute mais
pourquoi nom de dieu pour avoir des gens
qui écoutent ils paraissent guillaume
durand est devenu écologiste
ah bon mais comment il est fait il a
regardé l'audience de ces émissions
et ça l'a rendu vers c'est de la
dynamite ce truc là très efficace
l'audience a plongé comme un plongeur a
et ça ça marche à tous les coups un
problème cesap aventis à pune c'est
qu'il veut pas mourir mons à tournai un
nom un il veut rester en vie dans un
poney oui oui vous allez chez dunod
ça c'est bizarre oui çà çà çà zac ne
vous aurait pas lécher saint-palais cher
à nous la mulana là qu'on peut pour le
naval à l'audience professeur oui oui
oui mon dieu mon dieu je regarde mon
ordinateur les temps près la la la scène
mais c'est bercy
beshro il va falloir que vous le tu y es
sur les sons hollow lol lol j'ai de
cibler le chien on a vu un noir
morato c'est moi c'est non non bateau
jambes et puis je termine mes cadets
rien pour toi dans cette émission par le
revolver
non philippe allez vas t'en vas très
peur je t'ai dit que rien pour toi dans
cette émission écoute des charges le jeu
ne peut plus être suffisant mais je
soutiens que j'ai fait l'effort 1 ou le
nom bon je m'en vais à lezennes approuve
témoins corti pas je m'en vais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus